From Gucci to Chanel, Topshop to Primark,
clothes industry heavyweights
rely on fashion forecasters
for next season's new look.
But advancements in
artificial intelligence
are about to turn their
art into a science.
Cognitive Computing is now
able to identify patterns
previously inaccessible to humans.
It can simultaneously analyze
vast amounts of global data,
from social media buzz to political polls,
making it possible to accurately spot
what's hot and what's not.
WGSN, the world's biggest
fashion forecaster,
now uses AI alongside
more traditional methods,
a move that could reduce
forecasting errors by up to 50%.
Trendspotting mistakes can
have far-reaching consequences.
H&M recently confessed to a $4.3 billion
unsold stock mountain.
Industry waste costs both
profits and reputation.
Technology could make the fashion
industry more sustainable.
By using machine
learning, an AI technique,
to match supply with demand,
unnecessary manufacturing
could be limited,
and fashion's environmental
footprint reduced.
Online retailers are cottoning on.
In the next two years,
75% of fashion retailers
plan to invest in AI.
But keeping up with tech
giants is going to be tough.
Amazon is now developing what's
believed to be the world's
first AI fashion designer.
It plans to use an algorithm
that designs clothes
by analyzing images and
copying popular styles,
using them to build
completely new designs.
This technological makeover
could hold huge benefits,
especially for those
who like to shop online.
A Japanese company has unveiled the ZOZO,
a body measurement suit
that will ensure the clothes
you order fit you perfectly,
all meaning our future
wardrobes could contain clothes
designed for us and sold
to us by technology alone.